من هو يفقيني الذي يلقب بطباخ بوتين
مؤسس مجموعه فاغنر الروسيه التي يفترض
انها تشكل 10% من جميع القوات الروسيه في
اوكرانيا لكن مهارات بيروجين لن تقتصر على
ساحات المعركه كونه رجل اعمال يقوم بدور
قائد عسكري صنع ثروته من خدمات اعداد
وتقديم الطعام في التسعينيات خاصه في
المناسبات الرسميه في الكرملين من اشهر
مطاعمه وهو مطعم عائم فاخر بمدينه سانت
بطرسبور اشتهر المطعم عام 2001 بسبب تردد
بوتين عليه باستمرار وهو الامر الذي اسفر
عن لقب طباخ بوتين الذي اطلق على بروجين
لكن هذا الطرف والرفاهيه وراءهما السجل
المظلم بريغوجين سوجن لمده تسع سنوات
بتهمه السرقه والنصب عندما كان في
العشرينيات من عمره لكنه لم يصنف كمجرم
دولي الا بعد باجنر في عام 2018 خضع طباخ
بوتين عقوبات امريكيه بتهمه تمكين موسكو
بالتلاعب بانتخابات التجديد النصفي
للكونجرس وفي 2020 فرض الاتحاد الاوروبي
عقوبات على رجل الاعمال الروسي على خلفيه
مساهمته في تقويض امن ليبيا وخرق القرار
الاممي بحظر توريد الاسلحه اليها وبعد
الحرب الاوكرانيه اتخذ مسار برغوجين
منعطفا غير متوقع حيث استعرض خلافاته مع
وزير الدفاع الروسيه علنا ولاول مره ووصفه
قائد مجموعه بالخائن اثر خطوه الوزير
بحرمان مقاتليه من الذخائر حسب بريجين
الذي وجد نفسه بين فك الراحه خارجيا في
اوكرانيا وداخليا في بلاده